hi I'm Chris Garlock and I'm here with
Michael Redmond dined on professional
we're gonna take a little bit more of an
in-depth look at this historic first
round game in the google deepmind
challenge here in Seoul between years
ago and alphago Michael wants you to
take it away okay let's just go through
the moves I have some things I'd like to
say about the game okay so so far it's
looking like a pretty normal opening but
with this move liesl is already playing
a very unusual move I'll have to look
this up to see if it's actually a new
move or not even I've never seen it
before but you know the usual move of
course is something on the upper side
right and it's a Google place here yeah
it's possible that this was part of a
strategy to do something off-book yeah I
think he was just trying to get off of
the database that Google has and do
something that was plausible at the same
time mm-hm
so I played a kakari yeah and black
start and also the fact that this sort
of starts a fight which is Liesel's
style and so he's getting a nice
territory on the right side the question
is what happens on the upper side
naturally white invades - yes
so now black has these two weak groups
white has this weak group it's a
question of who's going to attack who no
he didn't push there he played there
yellow and black played here and then
the peep and why actually played very
strongly here to cut black in two and
now black sort of has to handle those
stones on the bottom side but this is
this is really dangerous for black but
it's also Lee SEDOL style so I wasn't
really thinking that he was doing badly
at this way after the game he was saying
that he made some mistake in the opening
and so I don't really know what he's
talking about it this is a fight that I
would be a bit worried about if I was
playing black
but I think it's sort of something that
Lisa de likes to do anyway so I wasn't
expecting him to say that he messed up
in the opening and I thought that was an
honors date so I was sort of surprised
black extended here white white has to
protect these songs evening and in this
fight it's okay for white to lose those
three stones like if black had played
something like this it's highly likely
that white would lose those stones but
that would be okay if I can get a trade
with the center stones and some of these
black stones here but this these four
stones are stones that white cannot
afford to throw away so that's the
meaning for this move okay why is
playing a very reasonable sequence here
in a very difficult fight actually and
this was quite as you point out in our
live commentary this is this is quite
different from the games played with
fondly back in the fall well finally was
basically was not playing as well as we
sold us okay and so I think the alphago
was actually having a less of a
challenge an X but on the other hand
alphago is actually much stronger in
this sequence and so it's standing up to
the challenge doing very well
the team said at the press conference
afterwards that they were you know back
there in the control room you're looking
and and that that dis fight was the
overall was pushing pushing it to its
limits yeah because yeah it is a very
complicate it would be very complicated
fight for for professionals right my
child I think jump right and at this
point I think white played here and
let's just play these forcing moves to
and this black group is just sort of
barely alive right there are some
forcing moves like the hunted that came
up later in the game and let's saw white
pushes and now alphago counter-attacks
very very sharp move right it's a sharp
move it's not really going to work in
that it's not going to attack black very
much but it does give white it allows
white to put some pressure on black and
therefore get some extra moves as we
shall see
Black has to fix the shape here okay
white extends and black jumps out it's a
fairly complicated fight well there's
all these weak stones all over the place
like there's this weak group this week
through black is willing to throw away
those stones but there's still some
potential for black over there which
makes it complicated for white too and
then there's this weak white group so
there's at least and of course these
stones which are probably going to be
sacrificed but there's already for weak
groups with some potential for more
complications here it's a fortunately
for black this group is alive but it
feels like like leas is destroying
everything at alpha go and have a go is
not yes its fighting very well toe to
toe so much so it's playing a fighting
game much more skillfully than I
expected because that was sort of
looking like one of us weaknesses okay
yeah but I wasn't sure because it was
having a relatively easy time in the
October games and so now black plays
here white plays here and for the time
being these two stones cannot move
immediately there's a bit of a G there
some potential for black these stones
have been extended out into the center
and so they were okay for the time being
and so it's still white doesn't really
have time to move out with these stones
before saving these stones because
they're not alive yet so if Black gets
something like this next to sort of
surround these stones there's going to
be very cramped right y will be forced
to play a lot of bad moves or
inefficient moves to make a life there
so so white pushes out now this is sort
of consistent to what alphago was always
doing it in an ambiguous position when
it was playing for you it would always
play move close to its weakest group to
reinforce that weak group which is a
good good style really
so now black plays here this captures
the two stones here and at this point
during the live commentary we feel you
know black Scott
some territory there this thickness can
be territory it's alive here Yeah right
how substantial in that quantum
potential in this quarter as you showed
him forty points with one more move but
other than that other one that doesn't
have anything yet it it's looking like
Black has some potential at this point
that's what makes it confusing to hear
he said I'll say he made a mistake in
the beginning because if I had black at
this point I would feel that I had a
slight advantage right and it would not
be a decisive advantage because they
were comfortable I would be a bit uneasy
about this territory here mmm that did
get messed up later in the game and also
because of the fact that white does have
those extra forcing moves so I would be
a bit worried about something happening
there later because partly because of
all these white stones in the line here
also there's so much uncertainty because
that can be a big territory in that
corner if white plays the first move if
white plays a move here that is this is
so that that's a big difference if white
plays compared to if black plays first
and so there's a lot of uncertainty as
to how the territories will develop
there a big difference
just one move will make so I wouldn't be
feeling comfortable yet okay but I would
feel that maybe I had a slight lead so
white jumps in here again White's
handling his weakest group and also like
if black had played like a move like
this next this would put pressure on the
white stones and because of that white
would not be able to invade the sides so
the whole side would come blacks
territory and so that would be bad for
white so this is sort of a must move
black plays a car here this was a very
it's an interesting movie I think it was
slack but you didn't like this during
life I don't like I do like it actually
not you still don't like it yeah I think
white once would you call it an outright
mistake or just simply slow a slow-mo
slow-mo I'm not sure it's a complete
it's a it's a move that white has to
play at some point I'm just sort of
concerned with the timing right and we
there's a lot of variations you show
during a live commentary I mean there is
there is ammaji here there is there's
potential for play right without there
like this hey we should a lot of
complicated stuff so it's not it's not
it's not a little right but it's
probably the double the double - yeah
big yeah it's it feels this this is an
area of the board that white has to play
to make a very quick life in order and
so playing normal joseki moves like this
probably doesn't work very well for
white and so it's really good that white
is playing light moves quick moves like
this and so this sort of fists the
position so it's very good positional
judgment for alphago here so yeah I'm
pretty sure at this point just seeing
alphago playing moves like that
he said Oh already knows that it's not a
fake players really pretty good because
this is a position that doesn't come up
it's not going to be the whole board
position would not be in the database
nothing even close to it it might find
some of the moves here in my database
but it's using them in a perfect
position more or less is very elegantly
settled that's using them very well and
shows some good judgment not only the
knowledge of the moves but the way it's
using them in this particular position
and it also leaves some really nice I
don't know if a lot of time to go into
it but did leave some very nice ah gee
here because of here and here and it
what did splines up actually all that
stuff key okay so white I think white
played 100 here what are they and then
white switch to the corner now this is a
forcing move against blacks group up
there because black doesn't need to make
eyes so black makes eyes but this
exchange here
forcing here and now black has one eye
here and one I use the white left it at
that point and this is an important move
again because it's setting up then base
in here right which is what comes
and slided and mblaq allows the trade so
this is this is a ditch been hanging for
a while yeah well that's an important
move both players were sort of expecting
that to happen but this is sort of
within the within what black was sort of
expecting to happen now and then white
protected the corner and away that's a
really big move that white has to come
back to at some point because of the way
oh that's like that's something like
more than 40 points in that corner now
black squeezes here so white has about
10 points here in about 10 points there
so white has something in the vicinity
of 60 points black also has a three oh
he didn't play that oh sorry black has
something in the vicinity of 50 points
here at this time and so he has
territory here so hold that white
territory it's pretty close to what
black has and at this point black played
here which is what I think is the losing
move okay at this point black probably
had to play in this corner this is
locally it's a forcing move it threatens
to capture these three stones with
another move here but that's a but
that's about a difference of 16 points
okay so it's not really big enough when
you have big it's actually only about
the same size as an extensional inside
there and it's smaller than moves in
this corner so it was sort of a careless
mistake maybe and looking at this move I
sort of wonder if Lisa dole was maybe it
was fatigue because he was playing all
those games in the North North launching
cup because it is a it is a strange move
to pleat be playing so early since the
white connection there is not forcing
and with me this whole area here still
so just too so so why don't we show you
what I think blacks should have done
first
I think blacks would have just played
like this to live in the corner and now
a move like this which does take blacks
eyes away can be conned with a move like
this it connects back to the corner and
the good thing about this is that when
white connects there
later black will be able to answer that
move and preserve his it's about 50
points and in this area so that's an
important territory which in the game
was reduced or what white had potential
to reduce it which was very valuable and
black has plenty of - black has more
territory than he did in the game on
this side a lot more because he has the
corner and white has a lot less there's
there's a big difference in this case
and I think black has a slight lead it's
a it's a game that would go to the end
and the end game white would not be so
far behind it white would have to resign
I think it would be a close game but I
would be betting on black in the same
game I would have to really order I
would have to study the end game to
really know but that's my feeling what
happened in the actual game let's just
go the actual game black actually took
the one stone after which now white
connector now this leaves the attachment
here but also threatens to take this
corner big so black played here white
played this with this attachment once
black back down and then white played
this the youth that was a kid liked it
that was definitely a mistake white
could have gotten the same result by
crawling immediately right and just like
here immediately
right black would event what and why
would have had an extra Liberty here
which would have made a big difference
in the following ye'll sake right but at
that point it didn't actually have a
direct effect on the cane and now come
up the game black answered that you've
got the black oh I have to buy sorry
and then why played here to capture
these and it's a beautiful sequence
because white took the territory at the
moment white got into danger white had
the tempo or the initiative the sente to
move their save his stones and with this
whole sequence whiteness now established
a leading territory the connection
underneath here and extension here
become me I that's interchangeable
points and I was having trouble counting
it at the time but this point White's
plane is already pretty secure well if
you look at you
variation you know this gets closed and
black gets the corner and this white
gets everything white gets this yeah and
like it's this so the bit was like if we
assume a black move here since aspects
Turner which actually this is the same
as the game right the corners just is
changed to white terror averse so the
big differences in this corner there's a
very slight difference why did black has
captured the one white stone so this
there's a smaller difference here but a
huge difference here which would make
the game very close and I think it might
be slightly in blacks favor hmm not I
mean in if he had played the very other
way right in this face it's already it's
already done right with you and it's
basically because you can't pay black
can't pay they call me right and and I
say the game when he said a loss
resigned he was maybe a head on the
board it was close on the board so maybe
it was a pointer so head on the board um
no way he could pay the Comey right
right it's an amazing game I mean it was
just phenomenal because from from this
point when alphago for his play here it
felt that I had this plan yeah I don't
like them very well after that and might
sort of knew that white had to
accomplish something here mm-hmm
and I guess one of the things I'm
wondering knowing the whole game now is
this simply about sort of you know from
alphago's point of view I'm just closing
it down at that point it wasn't when you
were okay that's too early for that
okay all right well that's a great
analysis thank you so much we will be
back tomorrow with a commentary on the
next game we'll be looking forward to
seeing what least it all does I'm sort
of hoping she's coming back yeah yeah we
wanted we want a close match you have a
close match so thank you very much
Michael